el legado estrella del ex presidente
barack obama sobrevive una vez más la
corte suprema de eeuu voto 7 a 2 por
preservar la ley del cuidado de salud
asequible conocida como obamacare es la
tercera vez que el alto tribunal niega a
los republicanos revertir la normativa
al destruirla en forma es realmente
importante tomar nota de esa decisión
histórica una vez más la corte suprema
confirmó la constitucionalidad de la ley
de cuidado de salud a bajo precio y las
protecciones transformadoras que brinda
a todos los estadounidenses con su fallo
la corte también rechazó una nueva
normativa impulsada por los republicanos
para que los ciudadanos tuvieran que
afiliarse a un seguro médico privado
presidente joe biden asegura que el
obamacare da cobertura a más de 31
millones de personas una posición
opuesta a la de su antecesor donald
trump quien durante años intentó
desmantelar la es muy importante que la
ley del cuidado de salud asequible esté
aquí para quedarse con el obamacare las
personas con afectaciones de salud
preexistentes tienen cobertura de salud
éste brinda también servicio
preventivos sin costo y un seguro médico
a las personas de bajos ingresos tras la
confirmación en octubre de mi con y
barrett como la sexta jueza conservadora
de la corte suprema la tercera nominada
por trump el futuro de la ley estuvo en
vilo sin embargo la red y otros cuatro
conservadores votaron nuevamente por
conservar la salud pública en el país